è mio assistente chirurgo berlino
benissimo in cassoni sinistra intanto
sono vitale berlino deciso di
partecipare anche lui alla sale allora
nuovissima challenge si sbagli
l'operazione lo metti nello slang mai
uno radicamenti come funziona per
sociale già abbiamo qua il gioco
dell'allegro chirurgo tra l'altro io non
ho mai giocato per microfini di faccioni
giocato con l'idea di come spendono
super curiosa praticamente una volta a
testa dovremo andare a fare l'operazione
è togliere via queste cose dal paziente
organi sono cose dobbiamo farlo qua
nelle carte bros e sbagliamo e quindi
s'espone famiglie
prendiamo il paziente lo mettiamo
l'altra persona dovrà decidere che
ingrediente mettere nel nostro slide che
invece fai giusto e riesce a toglierlo
puoi scegliere un ingrediente da mettere
nel video super divertente live vuoi
farmi fare uno strappo
rosa io voglio fattibile ma vero io ci
sono team sert e io non ce l'ho qui ma
sono timorosi la mia paletta e verde ma
la maglia è un po verde scuro
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn
perché questa sarà una sfida all'ultima
operazione che il primo round vediamo
innanzitutto chi inizia la prima
operazione carta forno cha cha cha
condizione io allora mischia le carte
del rischio che la faccio scendere dai
allora scelgo speriamo sia qualcosa di
facile farfalle nello stomaco
quindi domani sono tutto un movimento
può aiutare dario eliminare sto tormento
e che è difficilissima praticamente
dario ha mangiato dalle farfalle ma
insomma dario allora questa è la mia
pinzata del chirurgo berlino deciso di
mettersi lì a fianco per assistermi e
mio assistente chirurgo berlino
allora praticamente non devo tutti ho
l'ansia ma come faccio a prenderla io ho
toccato i bordi mimì offerta va
benissimo riprova dai perché non avevo
fatto in tempo a prendere il bene troppo
difficile
ora tocca vitale e dopo vedremo che
ingredienti dobbiamo mettere perché già
so che è vitale dovrà scegliere i libri
non per me berlino che
mischia le carte e scegli vediamo che se
ti capita e l'articolazione ha bisogno
di una regolata premi la pinzetta tagli
un po provata a tajani devi togliere la
mia figlia del meccanico avete
vicinissimo infatti non so se si
riuscirà è fatta allora sono pronto
togliamo mai mai
tra un po complicato
altra possibilità ho fatto bene era un
ora abbiamo perso entrambi quindi tu
devi svegliarti ingrediente devo
mettermi a voce di contralto attenzione
perché se sarei molto cattivo anche
indossare gli oratori fare rosa mi ha
detto quindi dai sono gentile e ti posso
scegliere il bene quali viola quello che
è stato abbastanza buono non so dove
vuoi arrivare
forse c'è qualche tranello o è così
benetton ho detto monicelli per me va
meglio sei stato abbastanza bravo quindi
scelgo
se dico verdi ma non ci sta bene nello
slum di natale perde il match ci sta
benissimo nello stand di natale non c'è
una cosa perché non vi ho portato di una
colla presidente affittarla conforme sia
mischiarlo how diventerà un lilla perché
mischiato con la colla bianca diventa
lille che bello spero di non rovinarlo
dopo con gli altri turni verde albero di
secondo round carta francia sasso inizio
sempre più credibile stream che sia
facile
pomo d'adamo lamela dario ha ottenuto la
serba troppo stretta elimina il problema
ma non agire troppo in fretta è infatti
piccolissima che forse ce l'ha potresti
fare perché è impossibile di prenderla
dal tutto da col piccolo pezzettino di
mela che stanno sopra a mi tremavano
[Musica]
non si mangiano le mani ha capito cosa
stava qualcosa per ora la pangea interne
nuovo 3 sbuccia padroncino che dopo
possa scegliere come km 26 gli manca al
re e pancetta ma delizioso quel salume
ma senza esagerare se ne mangi troppo le
conseguenze sono mare mi sembra molto
difficile da prendere e signora di
questo qui c'è la giovane ha portato
dentro quindi che allora innanzitutto
scelgo per me allora scommetto il viola
permesso pensando di fare una sorta di
galaxy il canale dopo la faccio a
tornare con il verde non penso proprio
il co questo pigmento rota che fra un
effetto perlato poi dovrò scegliere un
ingrediente per te non essere troppo
cattivo altrimenti euro sarebbe il
preferito in vero che è rovinato dai
così diventa grillo riuscirò a fare
kalac cena bene pure messa anche stato
io avrei mostra ceo e allora la chiave
la basilia guarda chi ha visto andare un
mezzo proprio
ok il terzo round vediamo chi inizia con
un successo sempre dicendo io
incredibile mischiare devo rischiare
dovevo dire
prurito galoppante un cavallo beckham ed
è mangiato un cavallo a stop grande
ringrazia ma non riesce mai a passare
bisogna intervenire se il problema o
eliminato ma dario si può vedere un
cavallo pazzo a togliere come poi a
toglierlo visto che è incastrata là
sotto
vabbè impossibile guardate quanto è in
fondo il cavallo impossibile da prendere
dato tutto da dietro non so se si vede
comunque secondo me il più difficile
questo un elastico ma non ce la farò mai
come faccio
[Musica]
sono tutte le dovevo scegliere il mio
ingrediente va prima e caprotti la
matita era un po dello scrittore
forse quella è facile da prendere è qua
anche se è molto sottile ario ha sempre
scritto d'amore lunghe lettere che gli
han dato grande olori lo deve proprio a
mettere quella centrale è piccolino
piccolissima almeno e al centro
devo essere super preciso perché perché
si è emozionato mi sono dimenticati vivi
solo nella seconda parte di questo
challenge lasciati un b piace a 15
milioni che se faremo la seconda parte
in più è uscita la serie animata anit
stories secondo episodio
se non l'avete ancora visto vi lascio il
link sia nei commenti sia alla fine di
questo video vi lascio il quadratino in
cui potrete vedere il primo secondo
episodio è una storia fantastica quindi
mi raccomando non perdetevela ora vitale
dove sei gli ingredienti per il milan
allora dunque vediamo come posso
rovinare uno slide rosea bellissimo
allora vediamo io qui ho tre tonalità di
verde
potrei vendicarmi come hai fatto tu con
il nero però perché scegliere il nero
quando si può scegliere questo verde
militare quindi è bruttissima
almeno i metalli tuoi ha scelto il nero
per me ecco cosa può scegliere il mio
ingrediente io quando sai di natale
metterei le palline dell'albero di
natale dello slide di natale novità ma
sulle le odi e fattivamente loro
mettiamo i glitter
guardate l'albero di natale dovrà te il
mio ultimo turno attenzione se chiamo
chi inizia carta poi lo sasso ritenta
sarai più fortunato descritto ridente
sarà il più forte in sé così script
nascono elastico che c'è scritto ecco
cosa succede se fai troppo esercizio
venire infatti è meglio non fare come me
io faccio la troppo esercizio che però è
fuori dalla palestra ti aspetta il
precipizio
l'ecdc le basi mondo ecco io poi toccate
cuore infranto da sotto per il rumore
spiega il buon dario che sono tanti
pesci nel mare con il suo fascino non
sarà difficile trovare qualcuno da amare
si per andare devi smettere ma gente
queste cose interne concentrazione non
ci credo faccia in giù tutti si vede
nemmeno e si portano stesso nato vabbè
senti io anche se ho perso lo prendo lo
stesso
così dario sta un po meglio magari ora
allora io devo scendere il mio
ingrediente per lo slime di natale di
vita cosa possiamo scegliere vediamo io
vorrei scegliere dei glitter e risaltino
un pochino di secondo me l'inter non ne
vale la pena perché no perché la colla e
bianca non si vedranno bene figlia così
almeno tre mettere ingredienti
ti conviene un filmetto pigmento il
mezzo viola è chiesta live di natale
voli per il manto bianco la neve sulla
sila da evitare ecco finalmente making
riminese cosa cerco dai cerco di farlo
riprendere con questo nome john king
ok grazie anche se non so cosa sia tutto
mischiato a mettiamo ora è un grigio
verde dai vediamo se diventerò non messo
purtroppo di bianco ne ho messo
decisamente troppo di bianco come sempre
alla fine del video dovrete votare se
vinco io se vince vitale in base alla
bellezza di suoni smr the dust lane
facendo un cazzo sta volando tutto il
pigmento ovunque sotto il cemento
costruire una casetta di mattoni aree
andiamo ad attivarli così poi potrete
votare se siete pronti
ecco che news live sono felicissimo che
alla fine è uscito rosa veramente grazie
a evitare che mi ha salvato all'ultimo
che avesse il colorante rota e bravo
vitale comunque sembra una big bubble mi
ricorda tantissimo il colore deve
battere anche la consistenza però una
super big bubble masticata comunque un
piace un sacco e super soffice lucido e
il colore mi piace un sacco in rosa un
po più scuro sentiamo un po di suoni
bene questo quindi il mio slide che
chiamerò slime big bubble
vediamo ora quello di vitale
se però i glitter si vedono e si stanno
anche molto bene
desiderati e super carino è un po
parlato per il bianco che ho aggiunto
alla fine e il verde non è proprio un
verde verdissimo perché il nero ma l'ha
fatto diventare verde militare cattiva
di vita cattiva però carino dai pochi
pochi non c'è ragazze però probabilmente
ci saranno tante bollicine sentiamo no
non ci sono neanche nel pdl chiede se
proviamo a mischiarli miss colore
diventerà brutto vediamo crediamo sulla
super curiosa mischia ma che belli però
questi due colori assieme a stephen
ireland
da rosolarlo maggiorate che fluffy
stupendo un po unicorn oso wow
allora votate chi vince se vinco io o se
vince vitale nel sondaggio e ora vi
lasciamo qua 4 caselline cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite e buona visione
[Musica]